welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dollar Moore filling in for my
final day for David while he is away
well they didn't
House Republicans with their new
majority voted ilhan Omar off the
Foreign Affairs committee gleefully
they did it they did it while
putting Marjorie Taylor green back
on committees they did it while Lauren
bobert holds a spot on the house
oversight and accountability committee
they did it while Paul gosar and a vowed
white nationalist
also has committee here uh assignments
and Democrats showed up in force to
support congresswoman ilhan Omar I'm
going to play three clips for you one is
Eric swalwell
genius points
one is AOC who talks about the rampant
and rank hypocrisy of Republicans who
act like they're in it to to curb
anti-Semitism which is nonsense because
Kevin McCarthy just tweeted this a few
months ago
we cannot allow Soros and stire in
Bloomberg to buy this election get out
and vote Republican November 6th Maga
with a a grainy picture of the
Jewish George Soros
so it is not in good faith or believable
or reputable in in any way shape or form
that this is about combating
anti-Semitism in the Congress so if that
were the case Paul gosar would not have
a job Marjorie Taylor green would not
have a job and
dare say Kevin McCarthy would not have a
job here's Eric swalwell making some
Salient points gentlemen is recognized
for one minute
Madam speaker when I heard that we're
going to remove a member of this house
from their committee for anti-Semitism I
raced down here because I thought
finally finally in this chamber there's
going to be some accountability some
accountability from this conference that
continues to allow its members to root
for rioters
to show sympathy for the Insurrection a
conference that Harbors a wanted
international criminal and has members
who choose violence over voting every
single day finally and so I thought
we're going to hold someone accountable
for anti-Semitism surely it's the author
of this tweet Kanye Elon Trump October 6
written by chairman Jim Jordan October
8th what does Kanye say I'm going to
declare Defcon 3 on the Jews so surely
this tweet came down right came down was
deleted no two more months it was kept
up two more months
so don't come here looking at us for
anti-Semitism look in your own damn
mirror before you ever come over here
and I yield back
where is he wrong how is he wrong
Jim Jordan has his little special burner
account that happens to be the house
Republican Judiciary Committee Twitter
account
Kanye Elon Trump
whether trolling or not they're
promoting
a a a vile anti-semite
AOC equally fired up someone who's been
uh threatened by anti-semites in the
house not because of religion
but these vile actors these Bad actors
within the Republican Party
Marjorie Taylor green Paul gosar who
depicted her death
are still on highly sought after
committees watch AOC
all right gentlewoman is recognized for
one minute
thank you now
as also as a fellow New Yorker I think
one of the things that we should talk
about here is also one of the disgusting
legacies after 9 11 has been the
targeting and racism against Muslim
Americans throughout the United States
of America and this is an extension of
that Legacy consistency there is nothing
consistent with the Republican parties
continued attack except for the racism
and incitement of violence against women
of color in this body I had a member of
the Republican caucus threaten my life
and you all and the Republican caucus
rewarded him with one of the most
prestigious committee assignments in
this Congress don't tell me this is
about consistency don't tell me that
this is about an ABS a condemnation of
anti-semitic remarks when you have a
member of the Republican caucus who has
talked about Jewish space lasers and an
entire amount of tropes and also
elevated her to some of the highest
committee assignments in this body this
is about targeting women of color in the
in the United States of America God
don't tell me because I didn't get a
single of time has expiring my life was
threatened thank you
and crickets from Republicans
pushing forward
to vote her off committees and this is
this is racism
this is fear of other this is anti-black
is what this is
anti-immigrant anti-woman
as ilhan Omar herself will explain she
got the last word in this before the
vote I guess you got the second to last
word since Republicans did get the last
word I talked about this the other day
that it was a foregone conclusion that
this was going to happen
and now it has but before it did
ilhan Omar did get to speak
this debate today it's about who gets to
be an American what opinions do we get
to have do we have to have to be counted
as Americans
this is what this debate is about Madam
speaker
there is this idea that you are suspect
if you are an immigrant or if you are
from certain parts of the world or a
certain skin tone or a Muslim it is no
accident that members of the Republican
Party accused the first black President
Barack Obama of being a secret Muslim
it is no accident that former president
Donald Trump let a birther movement that
falsely claimed he was born in Kenya
because to them
falsely labeling the first and only
President of the United States of
America a Muslim an African immigrant
somehow made him less American
well
I am Muslim
I am an immigrant and interestingly from
Africa
is anyone surprised that I am being
targeted
is anyone surprised that I am somehow
deemed unworthy to speak about American
foreign policy
or that they see me as a powerful voice
that needs to be silenced
frankly it is expected because when you
push power power pushes back
representation matters
continuing to expand our ideas of who is
American
and who can partake in the American
Experience experiment is a good thing
I am an American
an American who was sent here
an American who was sent here by her
constituents to represent them in
Congress a refugee who survived the
horrors of a civil war someone who spent
her childhood in a refugee camp
none of that matters to Republicans
Republicans who prattle on about the
American dream and quote Reagan about
being a shining city on a hill
and yet they punish and ostracize and
oppress a member of their own body
because she's black she's Muslim
and she's a a former refugee
who became a citizen who him who should
to them embody the American dream
if they weren't vile pernicious
Hypocrites that is
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below